coolie in Elmore almost ahead sir shaky
beer mood IRISA up wall has a head
Habakkuk babysitting tacky messy she
knew there were like phone calls
stressing me we know you we know your
house and we're gonna find you and
murder you
it was kind of scary movie I'm Harry ha
so we need to see I'm in a coma this
project will make a huge difference
because you don't find these kind of
sounds lately talking about women
problems women issues so it's a huge big
deal and I think people will will be
aware of this issue and how dangerous it
is beautiful Vicki which I did it and
fast it miss I'm like a complete however
the song is about one in here in
conflict and large and each Robert
talked about the issue from a different
point of view the message that we're
trying to show me in this group is that
a woman can actually do something she's
not just a teacher she's not just the
cooking machine in the house no she can
do something he can be a leader she can
be whatever he wants and that's what
we're trying to say in this song we're
writing that you can just treat a woman
like she's you know I think
they actually believe that our song this
song is gonna change something it's
gonna let the word hear their story so
they got really excited from visiting
the religious camp the song actually
changed because they inspired us a lot
my dream is to have my voice in every
house to be the voice of the youngers
who can't stand for themselves why don't
we do a gun Nathaniel mwahaha